[Música]
vamos a nuestra revista de prensa con
Rosa Pérez más deu Rosa Buen día para
usted Buen día ancla nos quedamos con
las ganas Sí así es finalmente no hay
juicio por difamación las partes se
llegaron a un acuerdo en la cadena Fox
news y la compañía de votaciones y
tendrá que pagar Fox
787,5 millones de dólares a dominion
boutings el New York Times habla de este
acuerdo y de las revelaciones
vergonzosas que serían el costo de
ventilar pues las mentiras no
exactamente porque tal y como escribe el
New York Times y como comentamos ayer lo
que queda claro tal y como escribió el
juez a raíz de las audiencias previas a
este juicio que como decías finalmente
no se va a celebrar quedó claro según el
juez que la evidencia aportada en este
proceso demuestra claramente que ninguna
de las declaraciones relacionadas con
dominion sobre las elecciones de 2020 es
cierta lo que nos quedamos sin saber No
la que la justicia no va a poder
determinar es si en esta desinformación
propagada por Fox news hubo lo que se
llama una malicia real que es la
condición que debe hallar la justicia
para determinar que hubo efectivamente
una difamación en este caso como bien
decías contra esta empresa de votación
electrónica dominion systems que estuvo
presente en 28 estados durante las
elecciones de 2020 y que Fox news acusó
de formar parte de una complot de este
fraude electoral denunciado por Donald
Trump pero sin embargo señala New York
Times que los abogados no de Fox news
finalmente hicieron un cálculo rápido
entre el peligro de perder el juicio y
el golpe financiero que suponía pagar
estos casi 800 millones de dólares y que
finalmente eligieron El golpe financiero
sin embargo dicen los New York Times
dominion Ha logrado recopilar una
inusual cantidad de pruebas que entre
otras cosas demuestran que por ejemplo
el propio
el jefe el propietario de Fox news no
creía y no creyó en ningún momento en La
retórica no del fraude electoral y que
taquercal son uno de los presentadores
no más conocidos de la cadena
odia a Donald según escribió en a
correos en mensajes internos que han
servido de pruebas en todo este proceso
preliminar y son temas que queríamos
escuchar en pues las supuestas
declaraciones que ya no existirán y lo
dice político Robert gana de nuevo
exactamente
jacker escribe que este acuerdo es solo
el costo de hacer negocios para Fox news
que es un modus operandi no el digamos
actuar un poco sin importar las normas
No ni la moral ni la ética y después
digamos arreglar las consecuencias
pagando los millones que sean necesarios
y pone otros ejemplos como cuando por
ejemplo Fox news pagó 100 millones a
celebridades de Reino Unido aquí en
expió los teléfonos cuando pagó 50
millones a mujeres que denunciaron acoso
sexual en el seno de Fox news 15
millones a un presentador que los
denunció por discriminación salarial
etcétera y escribe político Fox
continuará emitiendo su basura y raper
el indestructible seguirá como siempre
habrá ganado una vez más y de hecho la
bbc Recuerda que a pesar de que este
acuerdo por casi 800 millones de dólares
sea uno de los acuerdos más elevados que
se ha pagado para resolver un caso de
difamación suponen menos de la mitad de
los 1.600 millones de dólares que exigía
en un primer momento dominio systems no
Y además pone digamos una referencia de
lo que suponen estos 800 millones para
Fox news y es la mitad de los ingresos
netos que obtuvo la empresa matriz Fox
operation solamente el año pasado no
Bueno pero es que lo que más sorprende
es que con todo este recuento de
escándalos y de pagos para evitar
los mayores consecuencias pese a todos
sigue siendo una de las cadenas más
vistas en Estados Unidos ahora vamos a
pasar a the Garden porque parece que
todo le pasa a Fox news no los problemas
que siguen ensombreciendo a Fox news
después de su acuerdo con dominio
exactamente Y es que dice de Guardian
que si bien este acuerdo impide uno de
lo que uno de los que iban a hacer los
juicios de la década al menos en
términos de casos por difamación no
acaban aquí los problemas legales de Fox
news y atención Ángela porque este esto
es bastante interesante te voy a
enumerar cuatro de los casos abiertos
que tienen la justicia Fox news el
primero sería con smartic que es otra
empresa de Voto electrónico que ha
denunciado a Fox news por difamación de
la misma forma que ha hecho dominion
System sin embargo no hay fecha
específica para el juicio pero una
anécdota en el escrito de la denuncia en
la primera frase dice la tierra es
redonda dos y dos son cuatro Joe biden y
kamala Harris ganaron las elecciones de
2020 segundo caso
es una ex productora de Fox news que ha
demandado a Fox news porque dice que los
abogados de la cadena la intimidaron
para que falsificara su testimonio en el
caso de dominion que la querían culpar a
ella y a la periodista María bartiromo
de que Fox news emitiera las acusaciones
de fraude electoral bien tercer caso en
este caso Fox news denuncia a la
compañía crickey de Australia un medio
de comunicación que llamó a Fox news
coautor no acusado del asalto al
Capitolio del 6 de enero no porque
digamos que esta empresa en base a las
pruebas aportadas en todo este
preproceso de dominion acusó a Fox news
de haber participado a crear este
ambiente que acabó con el asalto al
Capitolio y es en este caso Fox news
acusa a este medio de comunicación
australiano de difamación cuarto caso
los inversores de Fox news están
pidiendo Según reuters a digamos
directivos de la cadena registros de
cómo se gestionó todo el tema de la
fraude electoral porque quieren saber
quién fue responsable de qué para hacer
que los directivos y los periodistas
paguen de su propio bolsillo y no sea la
cadena Quien tenga que desembolsar todos
estos pagos de los acuerdos por
difamación bien todo un caso de procesos
legales Ángela que finalmente
Lamentablemente posiblemente se va a
acabar solucionando Pues a golpe de
millones de dólares no Y para solamente
terminar Ángela de Guardian dedica
varias varios artículos a este caso en
uno Sam levin dice dominon gana pero la
sociedad pierde este trato sugiere que
las mentiras no importa cuán peligrosas
sean son tolerables mientras tengas
dinero para respaldarlas y en otro caso
Market Sullivan dice la demanda de
dominion expuso como Fox daña la
democracia pero sin embargo en esta
columnista aquí argumenta que bien
cuando tú pagas 800 millones de dólares
por un acuerdo eres consciente de que
algo responsable no algo culpable eres
sin embargo nos quedaremos sin las
declaraciones que hubieran sido muy
importantes para sentar un precedente
pero nos quedan los análisis y gracias a
usted Por traerlos aquí a la mesa